well Chick-fil-A is a amazing
mod because Chick-fil-A owns the dirt
the building and they own the business
and so then they partner with what they
call operators like they're franchises
but they're not franchises because they
can fire you and all you have to do is
put $10,000 in and they pick out of like
10,000 applicants a year for like a 100
spots it's a 2-year vetting process you
have to have already worked at a
chick-fil for like 3 to 5 years in order
to be qualified for it the sales I think
it's it's over 4 million per location I
think it's 4.8 here's what's even
crazier they have better margins than
any other franchise and so since they
own the dirt and the land in the
building the business pays them back
right cuz they lease it and then
corporate gets a 15% rip on Top Line in
food and then they split 50/50 The
Profit with the operator after they took
off all the Top Line the average
operator makes $200,000 a year but
they're making 15% on that and then half
of the excess profit 700,000 a year off
Top Line and then the other two so
they're making like 900,000 a year per
location not including the mortgage the
appreciation on the building everything
Chick-fil-A did the slow and steady and
now they're unbeatable